a team of chemical weapons experts has
been sent to Turkey to investigate the
reason poison gas attack in Syria they
will collect samples and interview
survivors of last week's bombing that
killed more than 80 civilians Russia
vetoed a proposed UN resolution that
would have pushed Syrian President
Bashar al-assad to cooperate with
investigators Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson left Moscow last night after
high-level talks on Syria including a
two-hour meeting with Russian President
Vladimir Putin Margaret Brennan and
Moscow questioned Tillerson on what
Russia knew about the Syrian attack
before it happened Margaret good morning
good morning no cameras or press were
allowed in but we are told that
secretary Tillerson said the path to
better relations with the US should
start by recognizing that Assad must go
now he argued Moscow should play a lead
role in forming a new government to
replace him yet Russia continues to
reject the conclusion by US intelligence
that their client Bashar al-assad
carried out last week's sarin gas attack
you said you believed Russia was either
incompetent or complicit in these
chemical weapons attacks we have no firm
information to indicate that there was
any involvement by Russian Russian
forces into this attack what we do know
that the attack was planned carried out
by the regime forces and at the
direction of Bashar al-assad relations
with the US have also been on edge
because of the US intelligence
assessment that Russia meddled in the
2016 election to benefit president Trump
now Tillerson said the topic came up
just briefly but he made clear that
sanctions are a possibility if Russia
does that ever again Charlie Margaret
Brennan in Moscow thanks Margaret